all right we must i feel compelled to
look at yesterday's
a very full day of january 6th trump
riot insurrection coup
anti-democracy hearings held by the
january 6th committee in the house of
representatives yesterday was a day
where we learned some very important
things and we're going to go through
them step by step first and foremost
one question that we've been asking
about
trump world's view of the 2020 election
is
do they really believe joe biden stole
it
or do they know joe biden won but they
just say it to show that they are on the
team
the sort of subsequent question to that
is
did assuming trump really believed it or
not either way
when trump said mike pence has the power
to send it back to the state overturn it
whatever right that the the pence
eastman plan as it has become known
did trump genuinely think that that's
something mike pence could do or did he
know that that's not something mike
pence could do the maybe the biggest
revelation from yesterday in the
hearings
is that uh greg jacob former counsel to
mike pence told the committee
john eastman the lawyer who wrote up the
plan
for what pence could do to try to flip
the election
john eastman
said to trump on january 4th
this plan is against the law
this is a critical critical piece of
testimony take a look at this when
exactly did president trump know that it
would be illegal for mike pence to
refuse to count electoral votes right
here is one sample of testimony given by
one of the witnesses before us today the
vice president's general counsel
did john eastman
ever
admit
or as you know in front of the president
that his proposal would violate the
electoral account act
uh
i believe he did on the fourth
that was january 4th
two days before the attack on congress
okay so we're building a timeline here
all right trump
retrospectively is saying pence could
have flipped it i believe pence could
have flipped it would have been fine
you know i know because you watch this
show and i know you know this and i know
pence could not flip it the john eastman
letter saying here's how pence flips it
was bogus not something that pence could
actually do
trump was told that on january 4th which
gets us to our next piece of testimony
jason miller
says to the january 6th committee that
on january 5th
donald trump dictated most of the letter
claiming that mike pence could flip the
results trump was told on the 4th it's
illegal and on the 5th trump dictates a
letter saying pence can do it already
knowing that it's against the law did he
dictate this statement
we
he dictated
he dictated most of it i mean typically
on these
typically on these i might have a couple
of wording suggestions
uh or
um maybe i
you know have a
sense or a rough framework or something
of that uh but i know
with uh specificity on this one that it
was me and him on the phone uh talking
through it um and
ultimately the way this came out
um was the way that he wanted to so
january 4th trump is told
the plan for pence to flip it is against
the law january 5th
trump dictates a statement saying pence
can flip it even though he had already
been told that he couldn't and then in
this third clip congressman aguilar
points out that trump released a
statement that he knew to be false on
january 5th that is exactly the point
that we are making here and the
committee was able to make the same
point even though the new york times
story was indisputably correct
donald trump denied it trump issued a
statement claiming that the vice
president had agreed that he could
determine the outcome of the election
despite the fact that the vice president
had consistently rejected that position
let's look at what the president said in
his statement
quote the new york times report
regarding comments vice president pence
supposedly made to me today is fake news
he never said that
the vice president and i are in total
agreement that the vice president has
the power to act
mr jacob how did the vice president's
team react to the statement from the
president that the vice president could
take an active role in determining the
winner of the presidential election
so
we were shocked
and disappointed
because whoever had written and put that
statement out it was categorically
untrue
okay
so the full story as we now understand
it with regard to trump and we'll get to
eastman in a second the lawyer
trump was told january 4th this is not
something pence can do
trump dictate a letter dictated a letter
on j a statement on january 5th saying
this is something pence can do
and later falsely claimed mike pence
agrees that this is something he can do
none of that was true so that's trump
let's now go to john eastman
the next question is okay
trump was given this framework by
attorney john eastman
here's how pence
could overturn the election
we now know on january 4th eastman said
to trump this plan is illegal okay
let's dig a little more into that
when did eastman know that it was
illegal well he seemed to know it very
very thoroughly and uh significantly
we're going to look at a clip here
former trump white house lawyer eric
hirschman okay
says
he spoke with eastman on january 7th and
told him
you'd better get a great effing criminal
defense lawyer because you're going to
need it
not long after that
eastman started asking for a pardon from
donald trump
he knew
his suggestion was criminal let's take a
look at this clip mr hershman's account
of that call
the day after
uh
eastman
i don't remember why he called me and he
or he texted me or called me
want to talk with me and he said he
couldn't reach others
and he started to
ask me about
something dealing with georgia and
preserving something potentially for
appeal
uh
and
i said to him
are you out of your f in mind
all right i said i
said i only want to hear two words
coming out of your mouth from now on
orderly transition
now the screamer said i don't want to
hear any other fn words coming out of
your mouth no matter what other than
orderly transition repeat those words to
me
and actually
eventually you said orderly transition
i said good john now i'm going to give
you the best free legal advice you're
ever getting in your life
get a great fn criminal defense lawyer
you're gonna need it
right and then i hung up on him
he knew
they all knew that this was criminal
what they were trying to do and then we
also now have thanks to the committee
the email we have an email from eastman
uh saying
i've decided
i should be on the pardon list if that
is still in the works eastman was so
sure
that what he had done
was criminal
and exposed him to prosecution that he
wanted a pardon from then president
donald trump
these are not good people and they all
knew it was against the law and there
were other lawyers saying hey to the
group that's pushing this stuff you need
lawyers remember maga means making
attorneys get attorneys and that you
know rudy ended up with an attorney
michael cohen ended up with it's just
that's what it is par for the course and
they were saying all you people
should go and get yourselves criminal
defense attorneys eastman knew
and trump was at least told
incredible revelations from the
committee let's next talk about this
idea of hang mike pence all right
so um
hang mike pence hang mike pence was a
rallying cry it was a chant that was
relevant and prevalent on january six
twenty twenty one
uh congressman aguilar during
yesterday's hearings
said that a court filing indicates that
a proud boy's informant confessed to the
fbi
if the proud boys had been able to get
near mike pence on january 6th
they would have killed him it wasn't
just rhetoric hang mike pence the plan
was kill him if we get the opportunity
we later learned that they actually did
get the mob got to within 40 feet of
vice president mike pence at the time
check this out
make no mistake about the fact that the
vice president's life was in danger
a recent court filing by the department
of justice explains that a confidential
informant from the proud boys told the
fbi the proud boys
would have killed mike pence if given a
chance
this witness
whom the fbi affidavit refers to as w1
right stated that other members of the
group talked about things they did that
day
and they said that anyone they got their
hands on they would have killed
including nancy pelosi
w1 further stated that members of the
proud boys said
that they would have killed mike pence
if given a chance
we understand that congressional leaders
and others were evacuated from the
capitol complex during the attack
we'd like to show you what happened
after the vice president was evacuated
from the senate
select committee has obtained
never-before-seen photos from the
national archives that show vice
president pence sheltering in a secure
underground location
as rioters overwhelmed the capitol
at 4 19 p.m
vice president pence is seen looking at
a tweet the president had just sent
a tweet asking the rioters to leave the
capitol
after four and a half hours
spent on working to restore order
the vice president returned to the
senate floor to continue the
certification of electors
so
had they been able to get their hands on
them they would have killed them and
then you of course have
we knew what would happen fox news
trying to run interference here is john
roberts on fox news
saying well you know this wasn't really
that dangerous we subsequently learned
that the mob came within 40 feet of mike
pence let me get your uh thoughts about
this threat against the vice president
because some of the protesters who were
there on january the 6th directed at
gallows outside of the capitol building
now it's not to say that the vice
president would have ever gotten near
those gallows unless of course
the mob was successful in finding him as
he was in the bowels of the capitol
building right well they ultimately came
within 40 feet there there were concerns
for his safety uh absolutely on that day
there sure were and i think we're going
to hear about that john i mean when you
go back to that day and you remember uh
and we're going to see images of the
video of the vice president being
ushered down the stairs there
mark shaw mark short was with him greg
jacob who we've been hearing from
throughout the morning was with him as
well these were very very unnerving
moments and the protester video and what
they're saying on it quote if pence
caves we will drag him through the
streets is very um very unnerving very
unsettling stuff for any american
yeah i mean there's there's no question
that the protesters were riled up in at
least articulating their desire to do
violence uh if if a certain outcome uh
did not come to pass right and we
subsequently learned that it was within
40 feet 40 feet
of coming to pass that the mob would
reach pence so incredible revelations
and you know there's been a lot of
hemming and hawing about
oh the ratings or enough people watching
or whatever the case may be
um
we have to think about these hearings as
are they uh indicative of a necessary
criminal referral
for whoever for maybe multiple people
and legal experts increasingly are
watching these hearings and saying that
the answer is yes now the justice
department has said we're watching we're
certainly paying attention
whether it will come to pass that there
are criminal uh proceedings criminal
charges for any uh individuals
about whom we learn during these
hearings remains a question mark but
there is no shortage here whatsoever and
many of the folks involved correctly now
needing criminal attorneys let me know
what you believe will be the outcome
here find me on twitter at deepakman
we'll take a break and be right back
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount
join pacman.com
the david pakman show is made possible
by members who sign up at
joinpackman.com we don't have a money
tree or a coin plant of any kind out in
the backyard we depend on people who
sign up at joinpakman.com you get
instant access to the bonus show of
course
as well as commercial free audio and
video feeds of the show you also get the
daily show five to six hours earlier
than non-members isn't that great you
can sign up at joinpakman.com
with the coupon code big voting 22 big
voting 22.
let's hear from people in the audience
after some time away from live calls
let's start today
with harry from columbus ohio harry
welcome how are you
david can you hear me i can hear you
beautifully harry
first and foremost a very happy and
healthy paternity to you thank you
congratulations thank you sir i want to
get quickly yes i was at a wedding over
the weekend um and one of my
wife's
uh relatives asked me a question they
know i'm relatively politically minded
so they said to me after a couple of
drinks they said harry do you know
dave ramsey okay and i
am
not very familiar with dave ramsey i
mean i don't have a lot of assets
personally i have a 401k but that's
about it and
he
was like okay so dave ramsey
says said
very very good straightforward advice i
asked him why do you like dave ramsey he
gives very straightforward advice okay
like for example dave ramsey says if you
are paying off your mortgage you
shouldn't buy a bmw and that's what he
said to me i was
you know a bit perplexed at first i was
like okay there's
multiple reasons why you may or may not
want to buy a bmw and i'm sure a
mortgage is one of them but just what is
the point of you know dave ramsey give
giving people these platitudes like i
don't understand you you've got to keep
it simple though here's the whole thing
personal finance is simple
but people think it's complicated so
when dave ramsey then re-simplifies it
for you people go this is great stuff
because it's so simple but the things
dave ramsey says aren't always true
and he's a right-wing religious
ideologue who uses supposedly simple
financial advice
to actually just espouse right-wing
political beliefs i mean he's anti-vaxx
anti-mask he's talk he's anti-regulation
you know all these different things so
my my take is sometimes dave ramsey says
uncontroversially true things but you
can get those same things from a handful
of books in fact
i have a page on my website
davidpakman.com
finance where i give you 10 or 12 books
where if you read them you don't need to
waste any time listening to dave ramsey
because everything you need to know
about personal finance is in those 10 to
12 books and quite frankly you could
probably read three of them and get most
of what you need just to take the
mortgage example
there are lots of people okay now i know
this is not everybody but there's
there's plenty of people
who in a low interest rate environment
would say hey you know what
i could pay cash for this house
but
i want to get a 2.8 mortgage it's not
available anymore okay but a year and a
half you could do this i'm going to save
my cash
get a 2.8 percent mortgage
invest the rest which over time in the
market should make me seven percent and
i'm gonna get myself a bmw and it could
be a completely sane and rational
financial decision so i get that the
ideas are
meant to apply to large swaths of people
but almost nothing dave ramsey says
really applies to everybody so i i just
i'm not a fan it's not it's it's not for
me dog you know
yeah no i appreciate that i was thinking
about the bmw thing specifically and i'm
thinking you know what if you're 30
years old you've just got into a
mortgage but you know you really wanted
a bmw since you were 12 years old what
are you supposed to do dave ramsey says
wait till you're 60. i mean right and
this is why a lot of the a lot of the
other financial writers that i follow
you know people like
uh rahm sethi
nick majuli and others you've got to
balance things and not just put
everything off forever because because
to a certain degree there's a reason
that
you are trying to have a strong
financial position you know and but and
by the way
if you lease a vehicle
uh you might lease a vehicle through a
business which makes it a total tax
deduction
and you might have a mortgage and it
doesn't mean that leasing a bmw is
irresponsible i mean
i just don't know it's over
simplification
and guru vacation and i'm not a big fan
of it
i really appreciate you pointing out the
whole way that dave ramsey puts a right
wing spin on things that are unrelated
to personal finances right really wanted
to hear you flesh that out for me i
appreciate you taking my call and again
happy fraternity happy fatherhood thank
you so much thank you very much very
much appreciate the call
uh appreciate the opportunity
let's go next to
let's go to brendan from jersey is it
brendan or brenda it's cut off
uh it's fine it's brendan brendan okay
welcome
thanks for taking my call so um my two
topics for our question would be a 2024
question for the dems and a question
about economics that could be agreed
upon by both sides okay which which of
those would you think would be more
interesting let's do economics
so the first one would be with the
development of ai and robotics and lack
of general skilled labor trending over
time
is it time to properly incentivize
destigmatize and promote vocational
schools for skills and trade development
things like that 100
i mean listen i don't uh
i i'm not someone who just says
college is for everyone college doesn't
have to be for everyone and in fact i
think the statistics are that most
people still don't don't go to college
there's a couple different things one
if everyone has a college degree the
college degree is no longer a filter for
certain jobs and then you just need
something else is it now graduate school
is it whatever so so to in one sense
college can be the right path for some
jobs and other paths make sense for
other jobs
in addition to that uh particularly if
we are going to see the technological
change and advances that we see in
energy in fabrication in materials
sciences all these different things
we want as many people
as possible we need way more people
getting involved in the trades
in order to be ready for those coming
changes and to get younger people a lot
of these trades skew significantly older
and it's great now that there's a young
electrician movement there's a young
plumbing movement and all these other
things they're going to fix this problem
of having to flush toilets 10 to 15
times i know that the young people are
going to be able to do it but yeah i
mean listen a lot of those jobs pay
really well they are great opportunities
and when we talk about making education
more affordable when we talk about
student loans when we all these
different things we should be talking
about trades just as much as we're
talking about you know traditional
four-year bachelor's degrees 100 percent
cool thanks um i was just going to say
like would something like this be agreed
upon by people on both sides of the
political aisle and so if a candidate
were to just develop this as part of
their platform would that you know
potentially garner them more support i
think so the problem is just saying
let's let's pump up trade school
wouldn't be enough for either side and
so if you're on the left and you go
let's pump up trade school and do some
student loan forgiveness then the right
will say whoa whoa we can't do the
student loan forgiveness so i think that
one part would have significant appeal
but the question is um
what else is part of it and that's where
the disagreements would start
right right all right well um i have
another question but if if you're good
i'm good david thank you yeah thank you
so much we'll get to the next question
next time uh since we have lots of folks
wanting to uh wanting to get in here
let's go next to patrick from alabama
welcome patrick
hi david thanks for taking my call my
pleasure
uh so in light of herschel walker now at
admitting to two additional children
today
i was wondering if you had any advice
for raphael warnock's campaign to take
the win home this midterm
well for people who don't know um
herschel walker is the trump-endorsed
republican candidate he has one son that
we all know about christian walker who
has a sizable social media presence and
during his campaign herschel walker has
been talking about
the scourge or scourge as trump would
pronounce it of absentee fathers
particularly in the black community
herschel walker himself is black
and earlier this week it was revealed
that he has
one child
that he does not see and and for whom he
is an absentee father and then it was
known that there are actually multiple
others i think another boy and then a
daughter as well and so it's another one
of these examples of the allegations or
confessions and projection and they
don't even live by their own values um i
actually think that
in a normal situation
this would end walker's candidacy like
in 20 years ago this would end
any candidate not but a republican also
uh because this is so against their
stated values but patrick the thing i'm
wondering about is
in the modern
trumpian republican era
will the georgia voters even care about
this so it's really going to be a test
now if you're rafael warnock
how do you take advantage of it rafael
warnock has the benefit of being black
himself
and so
he may be able to and i don't know how
this would play okay i'm not giving
advice here raphael warnock might be
able to say hey you know what
herschel walker rightly identified an
issue which is absentee fatherhood and i
as a black man i don't even know if
warnock has kids if he has kids he could
say i am living
the values that herschel walker is
saying we should have he is not you
gotta vote for me and say i don't i'm
just thinking out loud here you know but
at the end of the day i don't really
know that it will make a difference
because if the voters don't care
about what walker does as long as he's
not a democrat it's not going to matter
in the end
yep i agree with that as well i think
it's going to be pretty tough even with
this coming to light uh for rafael to
pull it out oh you think warnock's not
gonna win
uh i think it'll be tough to be honest i
think even just with like you said the
state of values kind of be contradict i
think warnock's gonna be tied too much
to biden uh come november and the voters
are gonna punish them for it just
because of gas prices i mean in the end
as of earlier this week they're
basically running tide so i don't know
you know is that good or bad in georgia
in june i guess we'll have to wait and
see
all right gotcha well thank you david
thank you for the call very much
appreciate it yeah that's that's a
really interesting race um there's a
there's no shortage
of interesting races quite frankly
let's go next to nate from chapel hill
nate welcome
nate from chapel hill please unmute and
we'll be able to talk to each other i
see that you are muted on your end you
must unmute yourself sir
and nate last chance to unmute yourself
and talk to me
all right nate is insisting on remaining
muted let's go to drew from virginia
welcome to the show drew what's on your
mind hey david can you hear me okay i
can hear you beautifully
david um i wanted to ask you about
something that i in regards to
mass shootings that i don't hear either
the left or right really talking about
okay um are you familiar with a with the
forensic psychiatrist dr park dietz
the name rings a bell but i don't
remember much uh park deets
yeah
he's been he's been a uh
a um
witness for a lot of he's been he's a
forensic psychiatrist who's been in a
lot of high-profile court cases okay um
and one of the things he's talked about
is that he believes that
the primary
reason why we have so many mass
shootings is because
um
national media always
gives mass shooters such
major attention
anytime someone
commits a mass shooting um they will
always lead the story with sirens
blaring a photograph of the killer
um they will they will lead with the
kill total how many were injured um
uh they'll make it round round-the-clock
coverage
um and uh he has put out some videos
talking about how
this um has been shown to cause more
mass shootings um and he's given an
example before that there was a fad
going around i believe it was in the 80s
with people
uh putting bombs in other people's
mailboxes and the media would cover it
right and then finally the media caught
on back at this time that if we stop
covering this people will stop doing it
yeah and they stopped covering it and
sure enough the amount of incidents of
this happening
went down dramatically and basically he
recommends that the media try to
localize these stories as much as
possible
and make them as unappealing as possible
to every other market
and i i even wonder sometimes one step
further if
websites like yeah like you know reddit
twitter whatever should view this as
snuff material
um
in the sense that you know i feel like
these are tragedies for the local
communities
and not necessarily something that needs
to be on cnn or fox news
i am 100
sympathetic to this idea i think the
difficulty is the practicality and i'll
give you two two kind of thoughts on
that but
100
and and if there is no question in my
mind i'm not saying mass shootings would
stop if there was no media coverage
right we still got to deal with the guns
there's no doubt about it
but if
the shooters even if they themselves are
dead or are in jail and unable to see
the coverage
they know from experience that when you
kill 20 people it's national news for
days if not weeks
and to some degree
particularly for individuals who as
we've seen they often have no rel no
romantic relationships sometimes we
talked about this in cell thing that
often it goes on with the mass shooters
they want attention from someone and and
that is a that is a way to get attention
even if you don't name them right not
naming them okay fine you don't name
them but eventually the picture is shown
eventually people figure out who it is
i think the difficulty is twofold number
one
the the ratings that these things
generate for national media are
explosive
um and you know we cover shootings for
us they don't get good quote ratings but
we i i cover it because
it's part of the story on guns i would
rather not cover it at all i would
rather not even talk about mass
shootings and give them no attention
when all of a sudden the entire
discourse around guns and everything
explodes we cover us politics i kind of
have no choice to at least talk about
that
but these things generate such great
ratings for the 24 hour streaming and
news channel so that's one thing and
number two
objectively speaking
when someone goes into a classroom and
kills 20 people it is news in the way
that we've defined news so it's hard to
imagine a world where it gets no
coverage but i agree 100 with the
analysis that the coverage itself is a
problem
do you think at a bare minimum
there could be any type of realistic
solution where the mainstream media
networks could ever have some type of
this may be naive but some type of
agreement where they at least agree not
to show photographs of the killer
because it's not that part's really
not extremely relevant to the tragedy
in a sense and it's not at all relevant
to the tragedy but it's relevant to
corporate media weaving a story that
generates interest and i don't know how
you get corporate media to agree to
anything that makes ratings lower
because that's at the end of the day
what it's about
yeah
but i i completely agree with the the
assessment of parker dietz as i
understand uh you telling us what it is
yeah park deets um
it i feel like sometimes when i bring
this up uh
friends of mine are people who i know on
the left um i'd even posted this on your
discord and i was getting down voted and
i felt like it was because i wasn't
saying even though i agree i agree with
sensible like common sense we need uh
gun control gun reform of course
but i feel like when i if i don't lead
with that
like i kind of see this as the bigger
factor even though they're both
important yeah i mean listen take it to
its extreme conclusion
the extreme example would be imagine
that the shooter knew
no one would know about what they did
other than the families of the people
you kill and no one else would hear
about it if you look at the the
manifestos that some of them leave and
whatever else some of them would not do
this if they had a certainty that no one
would ever find out other than the
families of the people they killed and
no one would even ever find out the
shooter's name
some of them would choose something
different now maybe they would choose
something worse i don't know but i think
there is something to that but of course
we need to deal with the guns either way
yeah i agree
all right thank you for the call i
appreciate you all yeah my pleasure
appreciate it thank you uh important and
interesting let's take a quick break if
you're holding on to talk to me just
hang on a couple more minutes we're
going right back to the phones in a
moment
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon
go to patreon.com davidpakmanshow where
you can get access to behind the scenes
videos the daily bonus show the
commercial free daily show as well as
special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts you can support the
show for as little as two dollars a
month check it out at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow alright let's get back
to the phones and talk to a few more
people we take calls via discord at
davidpakman.com
discord
let's go next to
let's go to juni from chicago uh junie
welcome back
great uh um i'm glad we're back david uh
how are you doing today i'm doing well
good good um my question relates to uh
mike pence
and um his praise he's gotten recently
okay
so i've been watching you know the
hearings for the past you know a week
now and they keep saying
mike pence has a
save democracy but in my opinion it just
seems like mike pence just kind of did
his job
and he shouldn't receive the praise that
he's gotten would you agree with that i
completely agree i mean listen it's
similar with liz cheney like i get
there's some courage in breaking with
your party and she said hey listen trump
incited the insurrection and trump lost
and a lot of republicans aren't willing
to say that so compared to them you're
like wow that's pretty reasonable
but uh no you're elected to just do
basic things
and one of the things mike pence cannot
do is overturn election results and so
the idea that he saved democracy well
okay i mean i don't think he could have
overturned the election i think he could
have tried and made a mockery of himself
and you know the constitution in so
doing
but to call people
heroic defenders of democracy merely
because they didn't attempt a coup
is going a little bit too far
yeah that's something i i totally agree
because you know mike pence is still um
you know a pretty terrible theocratic
you know republicans absolutely you know
like like his uh policies are just like
like i remember because i used to live
in indiana and i remember you know his
anti-gay policies which were just
atrocious yeah you know so his this
praise that he's gotten has been fairly
nauseating because you know he's still
just you know
he did this one good thing but in the
you know his long history of being like
a you know a political person he's just
been completely uh terrible well it's
just it just shows how far we've fallen
it's like he lost and he left and we're
saying it was a defensive democracy
right and it's just it's
it's the contrast with what trump did i
get it but at the end of the day what
happened is he lost and he left
yeah i yeah i i just completely agree
with that and uh yeah yeah and i like
you i liked your insight so yeah so yeah
that's all i really wanted to you know
get off my chest and uh you know again
congratulations on the baby man thank
you that's really good thank you all
right judy from chicago thank you for
the call
no problem enjoy your day a lot going on
there in chicago you can tell it's very
very extreme
let's go next to sebetto from
pennsylvania or is it sabato
okay welcome
yeah
hi how you doing david i'm doing well um
all right i think the only well
the best chance we have at
at winning the midterms and uh
subsequent elections is to
you know the same way that republicans
use fear
i think we need to use fear as a
motivator
sadly and i think we do this by
by you know stating that if we don't
vote for democrats we are going to be in
a right-wing dictatorship soon and start
listing i mean be more specific because
i think too often we're not specific
enough about what that would look like
you know this will be a a right-wing
dictatorship where
gay marriage will be illegal sweatshops
will be legal marital rape will become
legal the age of consent will be lowered
public schools will be eliminated
abortions will become completely banned
uh police will have complete immunity
everything will be completely
unaffordable journalists will be
targeted and so on and so on
absolutely i've spoken about this before
the right
the reactionary right uses
fear-mongering to win elections
but they fear monger about imaginary
things
so when we say
we on the left need to do a better job
of just telling people
what republicans would turn the country
into we're not stooping to their level
because these are actually the things
that they want to do
uh they tell us we want abortion
completely banned they tell us we need
to give police more immunity they tell
us we want even lower taxes on the rich
and to overtly create this over class
and not to regulate businesses and all
eliminate the department of education
all these different things if if so you
only have to listen to them
whereas the things they say will happen
if democrats are in power
they won't actually happen there will be
no more u.s border of course there will
be deportations went up under obama from
where they were under george w bush of
course there will be a border uh it's
going to be communist and socialist
there's like no communist and socialists
in positions of power in the united
st when i say and when you say
we need to accurately present what an
unmitigated republican
uh uh power structure looks like we're
not using
fear in the way they use it we're just
telling you here's the things that they
want to do and it absolutely should be
done exactly yeah
all right my friend well thank you for
the call i appreciate it
yep all right there we go yeah it's so
it's scary stuff guys it really is
let's go to is it wes from salt lake
city or wesley it's sort of cut off
that's weston weston welcome
hi um i was wondering
what your thoughts are on
something i've observed with right wing
and conservative people
is that they seem to have a very united
states
centric world view yes like i lived in i
lived in argentina for two years and
there was free healthcare free college
and they're much poorer than the united
states yes
so and then we have other things like um
sorry i'm really nervous you're doing
great um
we have you know examples of other
countries that are you know comparable
gdp or
per capita gdp and they have much lower
gun
homicide rates
and
what would you how would you you know
i guess
my thing is is how do we convince these
people that these policies are possible
free healthcare affordable healthcare
universal healthcare or um you know
college free college
that would help us compete on an
international level
as citizens of the world um or that we
could lower
homicide rate by gun
how do we convince them that these are
possible because it seems like
they think
it's not possible but i've seen it yeah
it exists in the world the weird the
outlier is actually the united states on
a lot of these issues it's the u.s that
has
of the rich countries we're the one that
has this wacky health care system of the
rich countries we're the one that has
this amount of
gun gun crime and gun violence uh yeah
no there's no question about that
i think it's
unfortunately there's not an easy answer
a lot of americans are brought up never
really thinking about the rest of the
world and they think the united states
is just the way everything is rather
than realizing the
it's sort of like um
what's the the allegory of is it plato's
cave or what you know it's this thing of
when
if all you ever see
are the shadows cast
by what's behind you you would believe
that the world is made up only of those
shadows and only when you turn around
and you see what is actually there
can you understand kind of what the
world works like and if you grow up very
u.s centric
you don't go anywhere else you don't
learn about any other place you think
the u.s is quote normal and everything
else is weird but the u.s is actually
the outlier in in so many of these
different ways i think it's an
educational thing at the bottom at the
bottom uh bottom line
yeah it almost contradicts the world
view that the united states is
exceptional in every way right you know
we're underperforming in all of these
areas and if we really are exceptional
can't we do better than these other
countries yeah in many ways the us is
exceptional among rich countries in how
bad some indicators are among rich rich
countries infant mortality
is much higher than in many other
wealthy countries and gun violence is
obviously off the charts and the degree
of inequality is off the charts a
percentage of children living in poverty
all these different things and it's a
real uphill battle to climb i don't know
that there's one way to enlighten
everybody
hello
all right thank you i think we've lost
you but i very much uh appreciate the
call
and that is going to do it for calls for
today i'm so glad i was able to speak to
so many of you i will take calls again
and i hope to hear from you next time
we'll take a quick break
and be back right after this
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick tock
all right it's time for the mailbag you
can email info davidpakman.com if you
have something to say it might be
featured on the show keep it polite keep
it substantive keep it productive
yeah only like five percent of people do
but
we have a lot of those five percent to
be featured today uh let's jump uh jump
right into some of these max wrote in
and max very very upset
says will you admit you were wrong about
russia russia russia
david you incredulously made fun of
trump when he was talking about russia
russia russia you even pretended or
purposely were ignorant and said you
don't even know what he's talking about
will you ever admit you were wrong and
trump was right michael sussman is on
trial for exactly what trump was talking
about it turns out the whole russiagate
scandal was generated by the hillary
clinton campaign personally approved
hillary clinton then surreptitiously fed
to the fbi will you ever acknowledge
that you that or will you continue to
pretend like this didn't happen well in
fact uh i can't think of anything in
particular that i was wrong about when
it comes to russia russia russia michael
sussman was acquitted by a jury
now people are saying oh the jury wasn't
a good jury well that's the process we
have
um and i mean listen i never said trump
was going to be caught on video plotting
stuff with putin we were nuanced and
specific in terms of uh what what we
thought went on and uh so i'll admit i i
have no problem admitting i was wrong
about things when i'm wrong about them
max also writing also when will you
admit that the wuhan lab story is not
only real but leftists and big tech
censored us for years for talking about
it and you have no problem with that
same with the hunter biden laptop from
health story yep i covered both stories
um we follow evidence and uh that's it
max i'm sorry you're sort of living in a
fantasy world okay jumping jack flash
wrote in and said i watched your
rebroadcast of trump's wyoming speech i
quickly learned from your narrative
interruptions during trump's speech that
you're quite a moronic a-hole good job
perhaps your mother should have aborted
you what a beautiful message of peace
and love and productivity you know when
i get a message like this i really think
to myself
i should reconsider my opinions and
political views because this is so
it's just so respectfully written and it
just really makes you think
introspectively could i be wrong and so
i am going to revisit all of my
political views thanks to this email
isn't that beautiful okay richard rhoden
richard says that um he joined trump's
platform truth social which trump calls
truth central truth essential yeah uh
richard says so david i was jaw dropped
for the first three minutes after
joining troth central after that i
realized it's literally 90 trolls it's a
turd spiraling the drain yeah there's a
lot of bot like
and sort of troll-like activity on there
and i i joined sort of like as an
experiment you know i'm not really
expecting any kind of
uh major dialogue or anything like that
there
but uh i encourage others just to check
it out and the replies to the things i
post are extremely nuts very very nuts
um it could survive i mean listen they
quite literally cloned twitter the
website is just a copy of twitter and so
to the extent that twitter is successful
at least truth set truth social now i'm
saying it truth central at least truth
social is starting with like a a a
layout a user experience that kind of
makes sense but i don't know if you told
me a year from now truth social will be
huge i'd be like yeah maybe if you told
me a year from now truth social will be
shut down i'd say yeah that that's
plausible too justin wrote in about gun
control
um justin from dallas or jr from dallas
as he goes by says david relatively new
listener would love to hear your
thoughts on the debate technique that
gun rights folks use when debating gun
control of assault weapons they tend to
start lecturing the gun the control
advocate on the technicalities of the
guns to show their supposedly informed
knowledge it's ridiculous how would you
respond well
yes it's very popular when we start
saying hey look like assault style
rifles keep being used in mass shootings
there's a couple approaches they'll take
one is they'll say most gun deaths are
from handguns it's like yes that's true
that's a different problem there's
really there's there's really three
problems actually when it comes to gun
violence uh or organ deaths i should
better say it's
death by suicide with a gun
what we might call one-off gun homicides
which includes one or two victims
remember it's only a mass shooting when
it goes beyond that either to three or
four victims depending on which
statistics you look at so then you've
got your sort of like handgun typically
handgun-based incidents which are one or
two victims and then you've got your
mass shooting so one technique is
they'll say
more people die from handguns what are
you going to ban hand guns it's like
well no we're proposing different things
when it comes to the assault rifles
semi-automatics large capacity magazines
etc we want age limits we want you know
all these different things separately
let's talk about the handgun piece as
well so one important thing is to say
we have many issues with firearms and we
have different solutions for each of
them then they'll get into what is an
assault style rifle anyway i can change
the appearance of this firearm and make
it not an assault rifle but it's still
sort of the same firearm or
i can show you a firearm that looks
different but still technically is an
assault rifle
what we have to do is just kind of zoom
out and go okay but hold on a second
the same type of firearm continues to be
used in mass shootings frequently
whether i can identify every example of
it doesn't really matter we can have
informed opinions about military
conflicts without knowing every last
detail about military strategy or tanks
or whatever the case may be and it's
really sort of a red herring to avoid
talking about the most important thing
so you've got it you've got to take
control back of the situation i think is
the point i'm trying to make
aj wrote in about the night before the
january 6th insurrection and aj said
david sir
marjorie taylor green has the same shoes
as the person of interest in the dc pipe
bombing suspect the night before the
january sixth insurrection what do you
think david is it just a coincidence
dozens of people have written to me
about this and they've said
we have no suspect for the pipe bombing
yet
the gate of the individual sort of seems
like it could be marjorie taylor green
it seems like it could be a woman rather
than a man these are the i don't know if
that's true people people write to me
and then most recently
the shoes worn in the surveillance video
by the
pipe bomber
are shoes that marjorie taylor green
also owns listen everybody's right about
all those things
big picture
i agree with all those things it sort of
looks like it could be marjorie taylor
green's gate
it is these are the shoes that marjorie
taylor green has been seen wearing we
don't have a it's all true it's
completely circumstantial it's
completely speculative it is truly
starting to get strange
that there's still no suspect for the dc
pipe bombing
uh attempt from january 5th into january
6th i don't know what to think about it
could it be marjorie taylor green at
this point i can't rule it out but it is
very speculative and it should be
investigated for sure
stephanie wrote in and says thanks for
the membership sale david sir because of
your irresponsibly cheap memorial day
sale i have finally been able to buy a
membership to the david pakman show i've
been wanting to for a while but couldn't
quite find the funds sometimes sales are
not as amazing as they are made out to
be but this really was a great discount
and it made my membership possible super
excited to be on board and to be putting
my money where my mind is keep it up
your work is so needed
thank you stephanie you know i spoke on
a live stream last week
i was genuinely bummed out i got about
two dozen emails
when uh my paternity leave started
saying things like david i just signed
up and now you're on paternity leave
cancel my membership
or
i didn't know i was going to be paying
for repeats or
you think you can just abandon your
audience and keep my youtube
subscription you're out of your mind
and i was so bummed out because it's
like guys aren't we progressive aren't
we in favor of paid paternity leave that
doesn't mean you have to fund my
paternity leave but like i am
self-employed at the end of the day
right where where do you think the money
comes from and in particular from the
people that don't even pay
the show is free like there's a little
bit of entitlement in saying how dare i
take time off from something you get
literally for free you don't pay
anything for the show so i love that
a bunch of people
like stephanie and others later got in
touch and said david
uh
i i apologize on behalf of those people
those are not real progressives real
progressives would understand what's
going on here and the importance of
paternity leave
um
but it was it was a little bit of a of a
bum out moment like and also i i said
this on my recent live stream too
this is kind of why the right wins
because they you know the example i gave
was you've got all these right wingers
who fund charlie kirk do you think
they're watching his show or counting
his days off or whatever no they just go
this guy is saying the things the types
of things that we want said so we're
just going to fund it and that's it
and
this is one of the real differences
between uh left and right and we've
experienced it on the show many many
times before the right gets you've got
to just fund this stuff and let it exist
because you think it should exist
and uh you know counting days off or
talking about repeats it's a little bit
concerning all right there's there's my
rant i'm off the soapbox tom wrote in
about lgbt nomenclature and tom says
this is a semantics correction
suggestion
i think there is this is tom writing i
think there's a push to revert to the
initial lgbt instead of lgbtq or lgbtq
plus to stop the disgruntled size of
people thinking oh lgbtq abcd it's just
too much people that i know personally
that are active in the community always
say lgbt for this reason
i have never changed to be perfectly
frank
um
i i've been saying lgbt from the start i
don't think i ever used lgbt plus
or lgbtq
i have no um desire to exclude anyone
from any group with which they identify
um but i ha i am it's interesting it
hasn't even occurred to me to change the
word i use
because i know that my audience
knows exactly the group i'm talking
about
whether or not i say lgbt or lgbtq for
queer people that i don't which is i
guess you know a more general term
my my audience knows my views on this my
audience knows my my inclusivity on this
issue um so i've just never felt the
need and quite frankly nobody's ever
really corrected me that i'm aware of i
mean okay i don't look at youtube
comments but i i i think people sort of
get the point
of uh
of of
my the language i use but yes i have
noticed i am just i am seeing a lot of
lgbt appearing again rather than the
longer ones listen we're fighting for
people's rights let's get people rights
that's what i care about ryan says masks
are traumatizing but robocop guards are
just fine yeah this is a really good
commentary on the uh armed teachers
thing ryan says just wanted to point out
that forcing kids
to wear masks would cause irreparable
damage to children's psyche sure it
would save a few lives but we simply
can't risk our kids well-being oh but
let's go ahead and arm the teachers hire
an army of armed guards maybe even build
a few robocops at the entrance of the
schools they'll be fine with that right
yeah and the point is one i've tweeted
about previously
we couldn't do masks in schools because
it would just be too traumatizing to the
children but it's fine to arm teachers
send kids to school
uh with bulletproof backpacks and
ballistic shield blankets and all of
these things that's fine but the masks
were just too much it's crazy it's crazy
and lastly today from julie julie says
david sir i'm embarrassed and almost
feel sorry for the triggered
projectionist trumpets that think
they're trolling you most of us see
through their br blatant failed attempt
to own the libs and might find it
amusing if it weren't so sad you're
obviously doing something right keep up
the tremendous work thank you julie
julie adds a ps ps please don't shave
your head when you hit the 2 million
subscriber mark on youtube well let's
see if we can get me past the 1.5
million subscriber mark first and then
we'll figure out listen if we got to 2
million it would be such a major
milestone i would consider shaving my
head i i don't know that anybody would
care about it but i would consider doing
it
info davidpakman.com
send me your thoughts